- We always love the opportunity
to help out our community
so when we got a
call to do up a truck
to benefit our local YMCA,
man, we were all over this.
We wanted to put our own
special spin on this truck, so
with Ryan's absolutely
insanely gorgeous paint job,
right down to that had
turned silver leafing.
this truck's a winner
right off the bat.
But I kind of figured the
best accessory for this truck
would be a matching
custom chopper.
I had Shannon build the
coolest little chop that
not only matches
this truck perfectly,
but it actually fits
in the bed of the truck
with the bed closed.
Now, the cats who don't donated
this truck, Greg and Terry,
they don't know anything
about this chop.
So we're getting
ready to show off
the truck with the extra
added surprise in the back.
I'm honored that you
asked us to do this.
This is a double win for
whoever lays down the money,
because they're going to do
something positive for the Y,
and then they're going
to have a cool vehicle.
So thank you for
trusting us with this.
You guys ready to see this?
- Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
- Oh, boy.
Let's do this.
Here she comes.
- Wow.
First notice how she sits.
Look at the shine.
Wow.
- Look at that shine.
- Wow.
Absolutely.
Look at that.
Before we could even
think about the paint,
we first had to make sure this
baby sat and sounded right.
So we lowered her
down, and added
some custom 20 inch wheels and
a full custom exhaust system.
Then Ryan went berserk
on the paint job,
with satin black graphics
separated by orange pinstripes
and hand turned
silver leafing all up
and down the sides of his baby.
He also added in some
very subtle YMCA graphics,
so whoever is lucky
enough to win this beaut
will always remember the awesome
cause that they helped out.
Now, let's get down to the
pretty side of this thing.
Ryan and the paint
team went berserk
with some beautiful
literally hand
turned silver leafing There
is real silver leafing all
over this truck, and
every one of those
is turned by that
thumb, brother,
just sat their and hand turned.
And bro, there's some
special touches on here
specifically with you in mind,
that Ryan really went off on.
I mean, OK, right here.
Like you said, the truck
is not a billboard,
but there is your YMCA logo.
It's awesome.
Now, come around the
back with me, brother.
All right.
Because there's something--
there's something important
back here that again, Ryan
took the time to dig back
and you found a vintage logo--
The original logo.
The original YMCA logo.
Oh, look at that, yeah.
And then updated
it for us here.
That's awesome.
Isn't that beautiful?
Dude, you know what I
just noticed though too?
Oh, did we leave
that back there?
It's not like us to
leave stuff in the back
of a truck like this.
No, no, it's not.
It's not like us to leave--
It's kind of weird.
Yeah, we apologize for
just leaving stuff around.
Although, this would be helpful.
It may be a little
accessory that we
added to this beautiful truck.
Where is Shannon?
Oh, you got to be kidding.
Oh, my gosh.
Look at that bike.
Wow.
What do you think, fellas?
Good lord, look at that.
That is a work of art, man.
Yeah.
Wow.
Is that cool.
Package huh?
OK, so--
That's how you accessorize.
- That's quite an accessory.
- Check it out.
Wander around.
It's all gone in
the same flavors
as the truck, the
wheels, the paint.
Everything about it.
- My gosh.
Same paint.
It looks like Ryan
was busy on this.
Look at that air cleaner.
The YMCA cover.
Wow.
You know, Danny,
I'm not a bike guy,
but this bike makes me
want to get on and ride.
I mean, this is just gorgeous.
The wheels on this bike
match the wheels on the truck.
And now, I firmly believe
that when this rolls up
on the block, you
guys have got quite
the setup here to go together.
I just see hands
going everywhere.
- Oh.
- Everywhere.
Absolutely.
You dig it?
Look at the logo
here on the tank.
I just caught that.
- Oh, yeah.
Again, nice, subtle--
- Nice, subtle.
--tasteful, classy touches.
Really well done, Ryan.
That is very, very cool.
If you guys don't mind if
we show off a little bit,
we're going to actually put
it in the truck right now,
and show you how this whole
package is going to look.
You're going to
have to grab the tire,
because we're going have to
pick the back of the ramp up.
Kev, you and I will
pick up the ramp.
- Yeah.
- Grab the tire.
Just roll the tire.
OK, go in.
You've got the bars?
I got it.
You got the bars?
Yeah, got it.
Nice job, guys.
Wow, it does truly
fit in the bed, huh?
How about that?
Fits like a glove.
I'd say so.
Man.
Closed.
Wow.
Done.
You guys way exceeded
my expectations.
This is very, very cool.
I am so glad that Greg and
Terry not only love the truck,
but they love the bike, as well.
And I know that
this beautiful setup
is going to fetch good dollars
at this upcoming auction.
Can't wait to see this
baby come up on the block.
- Thanks so much, guys.
- Thanks, guys.
Appreciate it.
- Thank you.
- Greg--
- Danny, thank you so much, man.
--appreciate it, my brother.
Thank you.